Confidence. You either got it or
you don't, right?
WRONG.
You can achieve confidence through some
very simple, but weird feeling methods
in which you consciously hold your mind
and your body in a different way.
First of all, you gotta trick yourself.
"Fake it until you make it."
There's a reason why everybody says this,
and because eventually, you'll start
believing in your own "lie."
Now, the second part, and the most
awkward feeling is
changing your body language.
No hands in pockets, no wandering crazy
eyes, no fidgeting,
Stand up straight. Pull your shoulders
back. Eyes ahead.
We have a tendency to go inward. What you
need to do is very consciously go outward.
I highly recommend reading "What Every
Body is Saying."
It's a book by a former FBI agent about body
language. And he teaches you "power poses"
that they typically teach to authority
figures to demonstrate dominance,
and, you guessed it, confidence!
Eye contact.
It's incredibly uncomfortable,
but it can be a lot of fun. Challenge
yourself. Every time you and a stranger
make eye contact, force yourself not to be
the one who looks away first. I've gotten
into a LOT of fun staring contests trying
to challenge myself to do this.
Also, smile! Say hi to strangers. Talk to
people in line. It's so simple, but the
more you do this, the more you realize
you have nothing to be afraid of!
So as long as these strangers aren't
offering you candy that you're inclined
to accept, keep talking to them.
Most importantly,
get out of your own head.
Just get outta there! I do this by
focusing on the other person. So when I'm
in a conversation with someone and I feel
self-conscious, I put ALL of my focus
on them. What are they trying to say to
me? What are they trying to actually
communicate? And if you can put 100% of
your attention on the person in front of
you, then there's none left to think about
yourself.
Finally, when you talk,
(slowed) Slow. Down.
(rapid) Not that slow. But when we get
excited, when we're performing, or when
we're nervous, our voices tend to be
higher and faster. Which is interpreted
as nerves. (Normal) You know, when you
see confident people,
they walk and they talk and they act like
they have all the time in the world.
And there's power in taking your time.
There's no big secret to
achieving confidence.
There are actual steps that you can take
to get there.
It's like any other skill. You practice,
you work at it, and eventually,
you've got the hang of it!
And no one knows what you're thinking.
If you just walk and talk and act like
you're comfortable in your own skin, the
rest of us will believe it.
And you'll be a better person for it.
So good luck!
Afflicted, Inc., my second short film,
should be out next week! Aah!
I know I put a behind the scenes video
out for Emergency Call, which is our third
short film,
and everyone was like "Where's Afflicted?"
And it's been in post-production, but it
is finally almost done, it should be here
next week,
I really hope you like it.
I'm super proud of everything I'm doing
so far, and I feel like I'm getting better
and I feel like I'm learning,
and if I keep doing this for just 10 years
you know, I'll just be amazing!
So, I'm having the time of my life.
Honestly.
And I could just..jizz. Everywhere. Like,
"Thank you. Oscar. Oscar. Yes."
But speaking of how I can even afford to
do any of these creative dreams of mine,
thank you so much to Audible for
sponsoring today's episode.
You can go to audible.com/anna for a
free audiobook of your choice.
They have over 150,000 titles to choose
from, 12 of which are karma sutra books.
They have 12. Audio. Karma sutra books!
So how can you not go?
One thing I'm listening to right now is
The Tommyknockers by Stephen King,
which I LOVE because I'm just fascinated
with aliens, like, fascinated with aliens.
But yeah, you can get that, or another
free audiobook of your choice
at audible.com/anna. That's
audible.com/anna.
Thank you so much for listening, guys.
And watching, and supporting me, I
appreciate it, like, so much.
Have a good week.
Stay awesome, Gotham!
CONFIDENCE!
Hi, I'm Anna Akana, I have a Youtube
channel, currently.
I initially started getting into Youtube
because I wanted more opportunities
to act. As an actor, you wait around a lot
for auditions, for your agent to call,
and I wanted to do something more,
and get better at storytelling.
So that's how I ended up on the internet.
So Afflicted, Inc. is the second short
of the year,
it's about a company whose employees are
actually personified afflictions.
So they visually look like monsters.
Subtitles by Skylar Coland via Amara